When it comes to trauma, what if the reason you can't just move on isn't because you're weak? What if it's because part of your brain is still responding as though the danger is happening right now? In this episode, clinical psychologist EMDR trainer Dr Alex Button and I explore EMDR therapy, PTSD, trauma, grief and how the brain can finally begin to learn. That was then, this is now. Hi, welcome along to psychology actually. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent, a qualified clinical psychologist, and I'm joined here today by a fellow qualified clinical psychologist, one that I do know rather well. It's Dr. Alexandra Batten. Hi, Alex. Hi, Marianne. Good to see you. Lovely to see you too. Let's let what we brought right at the start. You are my EMDR supervisor
谈到创伤时，如果说你无法走出来并不是因为你软弱，那会怎样？如果是因为你大脑的一部分仍然在做出反应，就好像危险正在发生一样，那又会怎样？在本期节目中，临床心理学家兼EMDR培训师Alex Button博士和我将探讨EMDR疗法、创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）、创伤、悲伤以及大脑如何最终开始学习。那是过去，现在是现在。你好，欢迎来到“心理学其实”（Psychology Actually）。我是Marianne Trent博士，一名合格的临床心理学家，今天和我一起的是另一位合格的临床心理学家，而且我非常了解她。她是Alexandra Batten博士。你好，Alex。你好，Marianne。很高兴见到你。见到你也很高兴。让我们从一开始就开诚布公吧。你是我的EMDR督导。
and you have been for many years. And that's because you are just amazing, Alex. Thank you. But if people are watching this because they might be thinking, well, maybe I would want EMDR therapy for myself, or maybe I would want to train in it if I'm a clinic already. Could you give us a bit of an overview about what EMDR is? Yeah, sure. So EMDR stands for eye movement, desensitization and reprocessing. And it was developed in the 80s by a lady called Francine Shapiro, who had her own cancer diagnosis
而且你已经担任这个角色很多年了。那是因为你真的很棒，Alex。谢谢。但如果人们观看这个节目是因为他们可能在想，也许我想为自己寻求EMDR治疗，或者如果我已经是一名临床医生，也许我想接受这方面的培训。你能给我们概述一下什么是EMDR吗？好的，没问题。EMDR代表眼动脱敏再加工疗法（Eye Movement Desensitization and Reprocessing）。它是由一位名叫Francine Shapiro的女士在80年代开发的，她当时被诊断出患有癌症，
and was trying to work through that and process that and noticed that when she was going on a walk one day through the park, her eyes had been moving back and forth rapidly in a diagonal motion, and she felt less distressed about her diagnosis and what was happening for her. And then she consciously was thinking about what had been happening when she was walking, and that's how she noticed that her eyes had been moving back and forth really fast. And then she started thinking about using that. technique I guess for other difficulties that she was having not big traumas just
并试图克服和处理这个问题。有一天，当她在公园散步时，她注意到自己的眼睛在快速地来回斜向移动，随后她对自己被诊断出的疾病以及正在发生的事情感到不那么痛苦了。后来，她有意识地思考了她在散步时发生了什么，这就是她注意到自己的眼睛在快速来回移动的原因。然后她开始考虑将这种技术用于她遇到的其他困难，不是什么大创伤，只是
everyday kind of niggily things that were bothering her and realised it was having the same effect it was reducing her distress about events and she then went on to do proper research with initially Vietnam veterans survivors of sexual assault and had the same results but because she was then doing the eye movements with other people she was using her hand to direct their eyes and so that's where eye movement came from it was It was originally a therapy treatment for PTSD and still is, it's in the nice guidelines for PTSD. But actually what we know now is EMDR works for lots and lots of different presenting
一些困扰她的日常琐事，并意识到它产生了同样的效果，即减轻了她对事件的痛苦。随后，她开始进行正式的研究，最初的对象是越南战争老兵和性侵犯幸存者，并获得了同样的结果。但因为她当时是在用眼动疗法帮助其他人，她用手来引导他们的眼睛，所以这就是“眼动”的由来。它最初是一种针对PTSD的治疗方法，现在依然是，它被列入了英国国家卫生与临床优化研究所（NICE）的PTSD指南中。但实际上，我们现在知道EMDR适用于许多不同的临床表现，
issues because so many different presenting issues have an underpinning of trauma around them. So what EMDR does, I mean, there's lots of different neurobiology and explanations for it. But in a nutshell, for lay people, it's a way of like, if you think of a computer that's got lots of like, fragments, I guess, of sort of information in there that is not, hasn't been made sense of properly. It's kind of the same with traumatic experiences that the brain can't make sense of those experiences necessarily in the same way that it would with everyday events like having your breakfast, going to the shops, etc. You know, when something happens to you that overwhelms your brain's natural healing capacity and an inherent capacity to make sense of something, we get like
因为许多不同的临床表现背后都有创伤的影子。那么EMDR的作用是什么呢？我的意思是，关于它有很多不同的神经生物学解释。但简而言之，对于外行来说，这就像是如果你想象一台电脑里有很多碎片化的信息，而这些信息还没有被正确地理解。创伤性经历也是如此，大脑不一定能像处理日常事件（比如吃早餐、去商店等）那样去理解这些经历。你知道，当发生在你身上的事情超出了大脑的自然愈合能力和理解事物的内在能力时，我们就会得到类似
a backlog, if you like, of information. And that might be smells, sounds, thoughts, feelings, body sensations, like fragments of the experience from the time. And those don't get made sense of in the same way as they normally would. So what happens is people end up with a bit of a backlog, if you like, I say to my clients, it's like, if you imagine a cupboard in your mind that we've just stuffed everything in in order to get on with life. And then things in the everyday life will trigger that door of that cupboard to sort of fling open and bits will spill out. And then people re-experience those fragments of information as if they're happening again. So a lot of my clients will say, I know it was a year ago, a month ago, 10 years ago,
信息积压的情况。这可能包括当时的气味、声音、想法、感受、身体感觉，就像是那段经历的碎片。这些信息没有像正常情况下那样被理解。所以发生的情况是，人们最终会产生一些积压。我告诉我的客户，这就像如果你想象你脑子里有一个柜子，我们把所有东西都塞进去，以便继续生活。然后日常生活中的事情会触发那个柜子的门猛地打开，碎片就会溢出来。然后人们会重新体验那些信息碎片，就好像它们再次发生一样。所以我的很多客户会说，我知道那是一年前、一个月前或十年前的事，
but when I get triggered back into it, it feels like it's happening again. And that's because those fragments of information haven't been date stamped and filed in the other part of the brain like they would for everyday events. So EMDR, like I said, there's different explanations of it, but it's kind of like rapid eye movement sleep. People think it's sort of like rapid eye movement sleep where your brain is sort of defragging if you like backlogs of information through the night with the rapid movement of the eyes back and forth. And there are other theories like taxing the working memory. So you can't, when you bring up a distressing event and you are then part of your attention is
但当我被触发回到那个状态时，感觉就像它正在再次发生。这是因为那些信息碎片没有像日常事件那样被贴上日期并归档到大脑的其他部分。所以EMDR，正如我所说，有不同的解释，但它有点像快速眼动睡眠（REM）。人们认为它有点像快速眼动睡眠，你的大脑在夜间通过眼睛的快速来回移动来整理积压的信息。还有其他理论，比如占用工作记忆。所以当你回想起一个痛苦的事件时，你的一部分注意力被
taken up attending to something else like the presence of the here and now. or the eye movements, or some people have like headphones on that bleak or click alternately, or they might have buzzers, or they might tap themselves. We see videos of this online. That bilateral stimulation not only kind of activates and jumpstarts this inherent natural healing capacity, but it's also somewhat of another thing your brain is having to give up some bandwidth to attend to. So then you've got a competing demand on your working memory, which can take the heat out of the distressing information. But having said that, all of that is happening within the context of, hopefully, for people a sound therapeutic relationship. So they are bringing to mind the difficult event
占用去关注其他事情，比如此时此刻的存在，或者眼动，或者有些人戴着会闪烁或交替发出咔哒声的耳机，或者他们可能有蜂鸣器，或者他们可能会拍打自己。我们在网上看到过这方面的视频。这种双侧刺激不仅激活并启动了这种内在的自然愈合能力，而且它也是你的大脑必须分出一些带宽去关注的另一件事。因此，你的工作记忆面临着竞争性的需求，这可以减轻痛苦信息的冲击。但话虽如此，所有这些都是在良好的治疗关系背景下发生的，希望对人们来说是这样。所以他们会回想起那个困难的事件，
in the safety of sitting with somebody who's able to support them through it, which is very different to having a flashback and the stuff coming out, the cupboard in the mind and trying to manage it themselves. So that's like the layperson's version of what EMDR is. That's how I would, but obviously when I'm training, I go into a lot more detail than that. that. Of course. Thanks Alex. That was really helpful. I think I'm right in saying that Shapiro said if she was renaming it again now, when she's no longer with her, she's passed away, I think, hasn't she? But if she was going to be naming it again, she perhaps wouldn't call it eye movement. Because could you tell us then why we've got all these different ways that we can kind of use it,
在与能够支持他们的人坐在一起的安全感中，这与经历闪回、脑子里的东西从柜子里涌出来并试图自己处理是非常不同的。所以这就是EMDR的外行版本。这就是我会描述的方式，但显然在培训时，我会比这深入得多。当然。谢谢Alex。这真的很有帮助。我想我没说错吧，Shapiro曾说如果她现在重新命名它，虽然她已经不在了，她去世了，对吧？但如果她要重新命名，她可能不会称之为“眼动”。因为你能告诉我们为什么我们有这么多不同的方法可以使用它，
not just with eyes? What's the theory behind that? Well, so it started with eye movements because that's what she noticed in herself was her eyes of we're moving rapidly back and forth. And certainly the initial like pilot studies in the MDR in the 80s, it was all. And for a long time into the 90s, it was all sort of eye movements. So the gold standard, the research is around eye movements. However, what we now know is that tapping ourselves left and right, any form of bilateral stimulation, anything that is stimulating the brain, left them right, then left them right, whilst someone is holding in mind the difficult event that happened for them
不仅仅是用眼睛吗？这背后的理论是什么？嗯，它始于眼动，因为那是她在自己身上注意到的，她的眼睛在快速来回移动。当然，80年代EMDR的初步试点研究都是这样。在90年代的很长一段时间里，它都是关于眼动的。所以黄金标准，即研究，是围绕眼动的。然而，我们现在知道，拍打自己的左右两侧，任何形式的双侧刺激，任何刺激大脑左右交替的东西，同时有人在脑海中保持着发生在他们身上的困难事件，
and in the safety of the therapeutic relationship, also will have the same kind of effect. And this is why she said she wishes she hadn't called it eye movements because what people went on to find out, that is the tapping alternately, or people holding buzzers alternately or the auditory. But also there are research studies. There was a lot of stuff happening in Cardiff University over the last few years with veterans who were on running machines.
并且在安全的治疗关系中，也会产生同样的效果。这就是为什么她说她希望自己没有把它命名为“眼动”，因为人们后来发现，交替拍打，或者人们交替拿着蜂鸣器，或者听觉刺激。而且还有研究。过去几年在卡迪夫大学，有很多关于在跑步机上的退伍军人的研究，
that was their bilateral stimulation. And certainly clinicians that work with children and adolescents are very creative in how they're doing the BLS. You know, they've got children hopping from one foot to another or doing all kinds of things. And it will have the same. It will be stimulating the brain left, right, left, right in the same way. But the research literature is obviously much more around very clinically in a room,
那是他们的双侧刺激。当然，与儿童和青少年一起工作的临床医生在进行双侧刺激（BLS）方面非常有创意。你知道，他们让孩子们从一只脚跳到另一只脚，或者做各种各样的动作。它会产生同样的效果。它会以同样的方式刺激大脑左右交替。但研究文献显然更多是关于在临床房间里的，
you know, with the eye movements or with the tapers or the buzzers. Yeah, it's so interesting, isn't it? because I think lots of people who perhaps don't work in this space don't necessarily realize that in order for me to wave my broken right hand at you, that's actually the left side of my brain that's doing that. And then for me to point to the left side of my brain with my left hand, that's the right side of my brain that's doing that. So what we're looking to do and what we do and what we do manage to do with EMDR is we're activating both hemispheres of the brain. That's right, yeah. And there's actually, you know, you're sort of,
你知道，用眼动，或者用拍打器或蜂鸣器。是的，这太有趣了，不是吗？因为我认为许多不在这个领域工作的人并不一定意识到，为了让我向你挥动我受伤的右手，实际上是大脑的左侧在做这件事。然后为了让我用左手指向大脑的左侧，那是大脑的右侧在做这件事。所以我们想要做的是，而且我们确实在EMDR中做到了，我们正在激活大脑的两个半球。没错，是的。而且实际上，你知道，你有点，
So the brain is so complex. We will never know. We will never know exactly what EMDR is doing, despite all the MRI studies and brain scan imaging, you know, scanning studies that happen. We will never know for sure what the exact mechanisms of EMDR are, but there is plenty of literature out there describing different mechanisms of action. But I think therapists and clients get very hung up on what is it because of the eye movements. And then that makes them curious, well, how is that having an effect? And absolutely right, to be curious about that. But we also don't ask all those questions of compassion focus therapy or CBT or act.
大脑太复杂了。尽管有所有的MRI研究和脑部扫描成像研究，我们永远不会确切地知道EMDR在做什么。我们永远不会确切地知道EMDR的确切机制，但有很多文献描述了不同的作用机制。但我认为治疗师和客户非常纠结于它为什么是眼动。然后这让他们感到好奇，它是如何产生影响的？对这种好奇心是完全正确的。但我们也不会对同情心聚焦疗法（CFT）、认知行为疗法（CBT）或接纳承诺疗法（ACT）提出所有这些问题。
You know, we don't ask those same questions about talking. We don't think about what's happening in the brain. But I think it would be safe to say the brain is so complex that we will never know 100% what is happening exactly in the MDR and what the mechanisms of action are. But there are so many different theories and so many imaging studies that will show. So differences in parts of the brain that are lit up, if you like, if you were to scan the brain, lit up pre and post EMDR therapy for things like PTSD. Yeah, so it's impossible to say for sure, but it's definitely, it's not necessarily as clear-cutters left and right
你知道，我们不会问关于谈话的同样问题。我们不会考虑大脑中发生了什么。但我认为可以肯定地说，大脑太复杂了，我们永远不会100%知道EMDR中到底发生了什么以及作用机制是什么。但有这么多不同的理论和这么多成像研究显示了大脑部分的变化，如果你扫描大脑，EMDR治疗前后，对于PTSD等问题，大脑的某些部分会被点亮。是的，所以不可能确定地说，但它绝对不一定像左右那样清晰，
because there will be multiple areas of the brain involved in those processes during the EMDR therapy. So helpful. Thank you, Alex. And so if someone's thinking, well, what kind of things could this be used for and what what symptoms might someone be experiencing? I guess, for example, if we spoke about someone that had been involved in a multi-car traffic accident, what kind of things might they be experiencing and how might EMDR be helpful? So I've just given you a random thing so that you're not accidentally giving us client. I know you're very good at client protection, but no one client would ever want to think that they were being identified. So I've just picked something random.
因为在EMDR治疗过程中，大脑的多个区域会参与这些过程。太有帮助了。谢谢你，Alex。所以如果有人在想，这可以用于什么样的事情，以及某人可能会经历什么样的症状？我想，例如，如果我们谈论一个卷入多车交通事故的人，他们可能会经历什么，EMDR如何提供帮助？我刚才给了你一个随机的例子，这样你就不会不小心给我们提供客户信息。我知道你非常擅长保护客户，但没有客户会愿意认为他们被识别出来了。所以我只是随便选了一个。
Typical scenario that we might. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So, yeah, very common that we were, especially in them through insurance companies and stuff, that therapists will have people referred to them who've been in some kind of accident, usually a traffic accident, but it might be a work-related thing. But to use your example,
我们可能会遇到的典型场景。是的，是的，是的。所以，是的，非常常见，特别是在通过保险公司等渠道时，治疗师会接到被转介来的经历过某种事故的人，通常是交通事故，但也可能是与工作相关的事情。但用你的例子来说，
I think what you were alluding to there is kind of the typical PTSD type presentation. So we have sort of three different sets of symptoms. Typically we're looking out for as clinicians in what we call, simple PTSD, which are the re-experiencing symptoms. So somebody might be having flashbacks, which is like literal reliving of the event. So it feels as if it's happening again. They might be having intrusive memories, which are slightly different in that they still have,
我想你刚才提到的那种典型的PTSD表现。所以我们有三组不同的症状。作为临床医生，我们通常在所谓的“简单PTSD”中寻找这些症状，即再体验症状。所以某人可能会有闪回，这就像是对事件的字面重现。所以感觉就像它正在再次发生。他们可能会有侵入性记忆，这略有不同，因为他们仍然有，
person will still have a sense of it being 2026, but there's the hyper arousal that comes with that is feeling like. So they're kind of experiencing both, if you like, they know they're in there now, but they are literally experiencing some of the smells, sounds, etc. from the time. That's a slight difference. And then the other typical kind of re-experiencing symptom is nightmares. So people will report having bad dreams. And that might be like a literal reliving of the event or it will be on a theme. So it might be a trapped and can't get out kind of dream, which might be what happened in the car crash, but the dream might not be a car or it might be that they're literally having a nightmare of having been tracked in the car.
当事人仍然会有这是2026年的感觉，但随之而来的过度觉醒让他们感觉好像……所以他们有点同时经历这两者，如果可以这样说的话，他们知道他们现在在这里，但他们确实在体验当时的一些气味、声音等。这是一个细微的区别。然后另一种典型的再体验症状是噩梦。所以人们会报告做噩梦。这可能像是事件的字面重现，或者是一个主题。所以它可能是一个被困住无法逃脱的梦，这可能是车祸中发生的事情，但梦可能不是车，或者他们确实在做被困在车里的噩梦。
Yeah. So those are the re-experiencing symptoms. And then people will often have what we call hyper-arousal symptoms as well, which is where the threat system is very on. So they're looking out for stuff. They're very vigilant. They don't want to get back in a car. They're very triggered by like the sound of braking or sirens or, you know,
是的。所以这些是再体验症状。然后人们通常也会有我们所说的过度觉醒症状，这就是威胁系统非常活跃的时候。所以他们会留意周围的事情。他们非常警惕。他们不想再坐车。他们很容易被刹车声或警笛声触发，或者，你知道，
it's kind of everything's very on is one way I would describe it, whether that's all the senses. or the person's emotions are very heightened. So they might be very afraid, big start or response, easily jumpy, panicky, or angry. Some people are very angry. Or it might be a big old mix of those everything being on stuff. And then we have our hypoarousal or numbing or avoidance set of symptoms that we call it,
这就像一切都处于高度戒备状态，这是我描述的一种方式，无论是所有的感官，还是人的情绪都非常高涨。所以他们可能会非常害怕，有很大的惊跳反应，容易惊慌，或者愤怒。有些人非常愤怒。或者它可能是所有这些“一切都处于高度戒备”状态的混合体。然后我们有我们的低觉醒或麻木或回避症状组，我们称之为，
which is kind of the other end of the spectrum where the threat system can't stay on all of the time. So then people might find that their system goes the other way and almost like detaches from stuff. So some people will describe having no feelings about anything, including good feelings. Like they've lost all feeling for everything. They just don't care any more about stuff. They feel very disconnected from people that they used to be really close to. They will sometimes have stopped doing activities that they used to like to do.
这有点像光谱的另一端，威胁系统无法一直保持开启状态。所以人们可能会发现他们的系统走向了另一个极端，几乎像是与事物脱节了。所以有些人会描述对任何事情都没有感觉，包括好的感觉。就像他们失去了对一切的感觉。他们只是不再关心任何事情了。他们感到与曾经非常亲近的人非常疏远。他们有时会停止做他们过去喜欢做的活动。
It's kind of a real shutting down and loss of interest in life. which can look like depression and also the hyperarousal in PTSD can look like anxiety. So sometimes people who should have been diagnosed with PTSD will come away from a GP surgery with diagnoses of anxiety and depression. Often and it's only when you meet them and you start asking them, well, when did you become depressed or when did you become anxious and they essentially tell a trauma story. So PTSD is like the common thing that people would think of EMDR as being used for. And it's certainly in the PTSD nice guidelines.
这是一种真正的关闭和对生活失去兴趣。这看起来像抑郁症，而且PTSD中的过度觉醒看起来像焦虑症。所以有时应该被诊断为PTSD的人会带着焦虑和抑郁的诊断离开全科医生诊所。通常是这样，只有当你见到他们并开始问他们，你是什么时候开始抑郁或焦虑的，他们本质上讲述了一个创伤故事。所以PTSD是人们认为EMDR被用于治疗的常见问题。而且它确实在NICE的PTSD指南中。
for treatment for adults and children. But what I've noticed is, and I said this earlier, so many different presenting conditions often have trauma in the background, whether that's big trauma like something like a baby loss or a sexual assault or an accident or an injury of some kind. But lots of other people have the less obvious traumas and they might sit in front of me and say, well, but I haven't had trauma Alex. And then they tell me about long histories of being bullied at school, for example, or parents that were super busy, or they might have had a sibling with like a lot of medical conditions.
用于成人和儿童的治疗。但我注意到的是，正如我之前所说，许多不同的表现症状背后往往都有创伤，无论是像失去婴儿、性侵犯、事故或某种伤害这样的大创伤。但还有许多人经历的是不那么明显的创伤，他们可能会坐在我面前说，嗯，但我没有经历过创伤，Alex。然后他们会告诉我他们长期被校园霸凌的经历，或者父母非常忙碌，又或者他们可能有一个患有多种疾病的兄弟姐妹。
And actually the parents were so occupied necessarily dealing with the sibling that actually they didn't particularly get very seen and heard. And it's not the parents' fault. It just is what it is. And so what I'm looking for in the therapy I do with people and certainly masses, as you know, of what I supervise isn't the big obvious trauma where people go, well, I haven't been a soldier and I haven't been in a tsunami or I haven't been in a plane crash or I haven't got trauma. But actually we're looking at what we call the small tea traumas for people, which is like
实际上，父母不得不忙于照顾那个兄弟姐妹，以至于他们自己并没有被特别关注和倾听。这不是父母的错。事实就是这样。所以，我在与人们进行的治疗中，以及正如你所知，在我督导的大量案例中，我寻找的并不是那种人们会说“我没当过兵，没经历过海啸，没出过空难，所以我没有创伤”的明显大创伤。实际上，我们关注的是我们所说的“小t创伤”，也就是
the drip, drip, drip of the not so obvious stuff, but it takes its toll. And that can show up as like really low self-esteem, feeling really rubbish about themselves, feeling depressed, lacking confidence, or might show up as body dysmorphia. there's something wrong with me, you know, people that have been bullied for their looks, for example, or it might show up as an eating disorder, or OCD is a common presentation that I see, not just in my own therapy service, but in all the supervisors that I have. Yeah, it takes many different forms, but there's often trauma underpinning these conditions. Yeah, there really is. And I was just thinking, as you were speaking, like, I obviously do a lot of work for grief.
那种一点一滴、不那么明显但却造成了伤害的事情。这可能表现为极低的自尊、对自己感觉非常糟糕、感到抑郁、缺乏自信，或者表现为身体畸形恐惧症。比如“我身上有问题”，那些因为外貌被霸凌的人，或者可能表现为饮食失调。强迫症也是我经常看到的表现，不仅是在我自己的治疗服务中，在我的所有督导案例中也是如此。是的，它有许多不同的形式，但这些症状背后往往都有创伤。确实如此。我刚才在想，正如你所说，我显然做了很多关于悲伤的工作。
and people obviously can be completely destroyed by grief, understandably so. And I often think with people about when it comes to grief, it's whether we can help you separate the grief from the trauma. If we can get the trauma bits to lay flat, and they were like, well, I'm never going to feel any different to this. And I'm like, I often will kind of think about when I lost my dad in 2017, it all felt like grief. but actually over time, I began to think about key, painful bit.
人们显然会被悲伤彻底摧毁，这是可以理解的。我经常和人们探讨，当谈到悲伤时，关键在于我们能否帮你将悲伤与创伤分离开来。如果我们能让创伤的部分平复下来，他们之前会说：“我永远不会有不同的感觉了。”而我通常会想到我在2017年失去父亲的时候，那一切感觉都像是悲伤。但实际上随着时间的推移，我开始思考关键的、痛苦的部分。
So, for example, there was a bit where he was trying to walk to the toilet with the help of a nurse who thought that he was stronger than he was, and then he kind of faltered and kind of went to fall over. That really wasn't lying flat with me, Alex. And it's because with hindsight, that's not grief. That's a trauma, a trauma aspect. So when I'm working with people, we'll be like, let's deal with the trauma and often they will say, I'm actually happy to keep the grief,
例如，有一次他在护士的帮助下试图走到厕所，护士以为他比实际更强壮，然后他踉跄了一下，差点摔倒。那件事对我来说真的没有平复下来，Alex。因为事后看来，那不是悲伤。那是一个创伤，一个创伤性的侧面。所以当我和人们一起工作时，我们会说，让我们处理创伤，通常他们会说，我其实很乐意保留这份悲伤，
like because that feels important to me. Absolutely, absolutely. Like you, I work with a lot of grief. Sadly, life is difficult for people, isn't it? People lose people in, like for you and I, very drawn out experiences of losing a loved one, but for other people, it's literally sudden and both have different trauma aspects to them, don't they? But like you say, you know, I think some people worry clinicians particularly will say, well, I can't, I can't do EMDR with this person because they've only just lost this person and they need to wait several months to see. And actually that's a myth. Like you've said, it's the, EMDR will be treating the trauma of what's happened to them. EMDR will not remove a normal grieving process. So I certainly have a number of supervisors say, well, I can't start yet because I don't want to disrupt their grieving process. And I'm like EMDR, where. moment EMDR will only remove the bit that shouldn't be there. EMDR will not remove something
因为那对我来说感觉很重要。绝对是这样。和你一样，我也处理很多悲伤。可悲的是，人们的生活很艰难，不是吗？人们失去亲人，对你我来说，是失去挚爱的漫长经历，但对其他人来说，这简直是突如其来的，两者都有不同的创伤侧面，不是吗？但正如你所说，我认为有些人会担心，临床医生特别会说，嗯，我不能对这个人进行EMDR治疗，因为他们刚失去亲人，他们需要等待几个月看看。实际上这是一个误区。正如你所说，EMDR将治疗发生在他们身上的创伤。EMDR不会消除正常的悲伤过程。所以我确实有一些督导对象说，我不能现在开始，因为我不想干扰他们的悲伤过程。而我会说，EMDR，在任何时候，EMDR只会消除那些不该存在的部分。EMDR不会消除
normal, rational, valid. So whilst we will process with people to take away the trauma, like you say, let's iron out the hills, if you like, or the mountains in the story, then actually they will still have the bumps and the ups and downs of the grief. Of course they will, because that's normal. But what I've seen happen with people is, especially with traumatic grief, they will come really traumatized by what's happened. They are either completely flooded all of the time or they've shut down and they aren't talking to anyone about it. They won't think about it. They're massively avoidant to the point where it's causing a problem in their lives obviously. And what I've always, always seen with grief is when we process the trauma, what will happen is your connection to that
正常的、理性的、合理的（部分）。所以虽然我们会通过处理来消除创伤，就像你说的，让我们抚平故事中的山丘或高山，但实际上他们仍然会有悲伤的起伏。当然会，因为那是正常的。但我看到人们身上发生的情况是，特别是在创伤性悲伤中，他们会因为发生的事情而受到严重的创伤。他们要么一直处于完全崩溃的状态，要么就是封闭自己，不和任何人谈论这件事。他们不想去想它。他们极度回避，以至于这显然在他们的生活中造成了问题。而我一直、一直看到的是，当我们处理创伤时，会发生的是你与那个
loved one that is around as a traumatic event, that will get removed. And then what people get, what comes in its place is the good memories come back. Like they don't lose a connection. I think a lot of clinicians and clients worry, well, if I process this, then I've lost them. They're gone completely and that has never happened. In all the people I've worked with, actually, they get the good stuff about the person back. They get a reconnection with the person that isn't about trauma. But absolutely, as you've said, Marian, I haven't had anyone leave therapy that's had a loss that is going, well, I feel nothing about that now. But what they do get is a different. relationship to the lost one back.
作为创伤事件的挚爱之人的联系，那部分会被移除。然后人们得到的是，取而代之的是美好的回忆回来了。他们并没有失去联系。我认为很多临床医生和来访者担心，如果我处理了这个，那么我就失去了他们。他们彻底消失了，而这种情况从未发生过。在我共事过的所有人中，实际上，他们找回了关于那个人的美好事物。他们与那个人重新建立了联系，而这不再是关于创伤的。但绝对如你所说，Marian，我没有见过任何经历过丧亲之痛的来访者在结束治疗时说，嗯，我现在对那件事毫无感觉。但他们得到的是与逝者之间一种不同的关系。
Absolutely. And you begin to be able to assimilate it better into your life rather than it just jutting out like this sudden stone wall. And yeah, like it's sometimes with grief, like you said, it can be so sudden and there can also be bits where caregivers and loved ones are having to be involved in that. So perhaps they're having to do CPR, perhaps they're having to manage the situation, you know, over the phone with, and all of that can be an added trauma. that is just not lying flat. No, sure. So, you know, when you were talking to us about how trauma can mean that you disengage from your life and stop doing all the things that you love,
绝对是这样。你开始能够更好地将其融入你的生活，而不是让它像一堵突然出现的石墙一样突兀。是的，就像你说的，有时悲伤可能非常突然，而且可能存在照顾者和亲人不得不参与其中的部分。所以也许他们不得不进行心肺复苏，也许他们不得不处理这种情况，你知道，通过电话，所有这些都可能是一种额外的创伤，那只是没有平复下来。当然。所以，当你和我们谈论创伤如何意味着你脱离生活并停止做所有你热爱的事情时，
I just felt so proud to do what we do, Alex, because I just thought, God, we get to be in a position where we see people just come back to themselves and they suddenly like, God, I really missed myself. or other people start to notice that with them, like, oh, you smile or you did this, or you just seemed very different. And it's so powerful, isn't it? Tell us about how EMDR can help us to help people to reconnect with their lives again. Yeah. Well, I think, you know, like I was saying, sometimes people are, they haven't meant to cut off. They're just, you know, like the head has had to carry on life. doing life, you know, but the feelings aren't allowed to be around because they're too overwhelming.
我感到非常自豪能做我们所做的事情，Alex，因为我只是想，天哪，我们处于一个能够看到人们回归自我的位置，他们突然觉得，天哪，我真的很想念我自己。或者其他人开始注意到他们的变化，比如，哦，你笑了，或者你做了这个，或者你看起来很不一样。这太强大了，不是吗？告诉我们EMDR如何能帮助我们帮助人们重新与他们的生活建立联系。是的。嗯，我想，你知道，就像我刚才说的，有时人们，他们并不是故意要切断联系。他们只是，你知道，就像大脑不得不继续生活，处理生活，你知道，但这些感受不被允许存在，因为它们太令人难以承受了。
And so what EMDR will do is if we can bring, if we can bring up, like you just gave me an example of what we would call a target in EMDR when that moment where your dad had his stumble. And for you, that just wasn't settling. We would call that a target in EMDR. I call them hotspots with people typically. Because within, you know, often it's a chapter in someone's life, isn't it? It's not a one off event that happened in a split second and was done. You know, often we're working with people on things that have gone on for hours, weeks, months, years, sometimes. And so we look in the story for what these particular hot moments, if you like.
所以EMDR会做的是，如果我们能带出，如果我们能带出，就像你刚才给我的例子，我们在EMDR中称之为“目标”，当你父亲踉跄的那一刻。对你来说，那件事一直没有平复。我们在EMDR中会称之为目标。我通常称它们为“热点”。因为在，你知道，通常这是一个人的生活中的一个章节，不是吗？这不是一个在瞬间发生并结束的单一事件。你知道，我们经常与人们一起处理那些持续了数小时、数周、数月，有时甚至是数年的事情。所以我们在故事中寻找这些特定的热点时刻。
And in EMDR, we would prime that moment. So we'd get those fragments out the cupboard. We would have created the safe relationship and the safe space. And then we would be allowing the brain time to decompress, I guess, like defrag that difficult moment. until it's not as overwhelming anymore. And then the person will, well, let me say it another way. I had one client many years, many years ago who summed up, I think, what EMDR does really, really nicely.
在EMDR中，我们会对那个时刻进行预处理。所以我们会把那些碎片从柜子里拿出来。我们会创造安全的关系和安全的空间。然后我们会让大脑有时间去解压，我想，就像对那个困难的时刻进行碎片整理一样。直到它不再那么令人难以承受。然后那个人会，嗯，让我换个说法。很多年前，我有一位来访者，她总结了我觉得EMDR做得非常、非常好的地方。
And I used this example on my trainings. So she had actually had a car crash. And she had gone to see a therapist for CBT. That was what she was, you know, and brightly so trauma-focused CBT was completely appropriate according to the nice guidelines. but it hadn't it hadn't worked it hadn't taken the edge off and then she came to see me for EMDR and um when we'd done the EMDR and it had been really successful I asked her what was different you've had both and she said you know I feel like CBT was going if you can think differently about this you
我在我的培训中使用了这个例子。她实际上经历了一场车祸。她去看了一位CBT治疗师。这就是她所做的，你知道，而且确实，创伤聚焦CBT根据NICE指南是完全合适的。但它没有奏效，它没有减轻痛苦。然后她来看我进行EMDR，嗯，当我们做完EMDR，而且非常成功时，我问她有什么不同，你两者都经历过，她说，你知道，我觉得CBT就像是说，如果你能换个角度思考这件事，你
will feel differently about it she said but I couldn't do that because when the feelings showed up they were so strong that I couldn't think rationally and what we did in the MDR is we made space for the feelings and we processed the feelings about what had happened, they dialed down and then naturally I thought differently about stuff. And I think that's some way of answering your question. How do people reconnect with life? Because when people have got, often with traumatic events, people will have a number of negative beliefs, either about themselves,
就会对它有不同的感受，她说，但我做不到，因为当感受出现时，它们太强烈了，以至于我无法理性思考。而我们在EMDR中所做的是，我们为感受腾出了空间，我们处理了关于所发生之事的感受，它们减弱了，然后我自然而然地对事情有了不同的看法。我想这就是回答你问题的一种方式。人们如何重新与生活建立联系？因为当人们有，通常在创伤事件中，人们会有许多负面信念，要么是关于他们自己的，
other people, the world. That might be, I'm a failure. I get things wrong. I mess up or I'm in danger or I'm not in control. other people are not trustworthy, the world isn't safe. And so people learn to shut down and cut off because that is self-preservation. Actually, when these beliefs shift in therapy, which they do, when the high distress comes down, the thinking brain will come back online more naturally. And then people can re-engage with life because not only are they not disconnected from it anymore because their feelings
关于其他人，关于世界。那可能是，我是个失败者。我把事情搞砸了。我弄乱了，或者我处于危险之中，或者我无法控制。其他人不可信，世界不安全。所以人们学会了封闭和切断联系，因为那是自我保护。实际上，当这些信念在治疗中发生转变时，确实如此，当高度的痛苦降低时，思考的大脑会更自然地重新上线。然后人们可以重新参与生活，因为他们不仅不再与生活脱节，因为他们的感受
about stuff do start to come back, but in a healthy way, like we said with the grief. they, when their beliefs shift into much healthier sets of beliefs, like I'm okay, it's over, I'm good enough, other people are, you know, some people are trustworthy, the world is safe enough, then they can venture into life again, you know, feeling more robust and that's what helps people reconnect with people, places, activities that they used to enjoy. It really does and it can be such a visceral experience to, to carry trauma. I'm reminded of a case I worked with. And whilst EMDR breakthroughs don't all happen at the same time in session one, we often will get what John Burnham in systemic therapy refers to as magic moments, where you can literally just have this real transformational moment. And I had this experience in EMDR with a client where at the end of the session,
关于事情确实开始回归，但以一种健康的方式，就像我们谈论悲伤时那样。当他们的信念转变为更健康的信念集时，比如“我很好，一切都结束了，我足够好了，其他人是，你知道，有些人是值得信赖的，世界足够安全”，那么他们就可以再次冒险进入生活，你知道，感觉更强健，这就是帮助人们重新与他们曾经享受的人、地点、活动建立联系的原因。确实如此，携带创伤可能是一种非常发自内心的体验。我想起了一个我处理过的案例。虽然EMDR的突破并不都在第一次会话中发生，但我们经常会得到John Burnham在系统式治疗中所说的“神奇时刻”，在那里你可以字面上拥有这种真正的转化时刻。我在EMDR中与一位来访者有过这种经历，在会话结束时，
they said, well, it feels like I've put down these heavy shopping bags that I've been carrying for almost 10 years that I didn't realize I was carrying. And then today in this room is the first time I've realized what a weight that has been and what a relief it is to not have to carry that anymore. And then was able to really clearly say, well, now when I look back at that, that does feel like it's been getting on for 10 years ago,
他们说，嗯，感觉就像我放下了我背了近10年的沉重的购物袋，而我并没有意识到我在背着它们。然后今天在这个房间里，是我第一次意识到那是一个多么沉重的负担，不再需要背负它是一种多么大的解脱。然后能够非常清楚地说，嗯，现在当我回顾那件事时，那确实感觉像是快10年前的事了，
was when I walked in here this morning, that felt like it was now. like I couldn't get that time that time distinction, that filing cabinet label that we often think about. I just couldn't get it. It was so loose and fluid. Yeah. So people will say, you know, it feels like now, like when it shows up, when the cupboard flings open, it's literally happening again. And because of that, send off the person's threat system, their alarm system in their body will go again. So it makes them feel like it's literally happening again. And people feel like they're going mad because they'll say, well, I know it's over, but I don't feel like that. And that's the difference I think
当我今天早上走进这里时，感觉就像是现在。就像我无法区分那个时间，那个我们经常想到的文件柜标签。我就是无法做到。它是如此松散和流动。是的。所以人们会说，你知道，感觉就像现在，当它出现时，当柜门猛地打开时，它字面上正在再次发生。正因为如此，触发了那个人的威胁系统，他们身体里的警报系统会再次启动。所以这让他们觉得它字面上正在再次发生。人们觉得他们快疯了，因为他们会说，嗯，我知道它结束了，但我不觉得是这样。这就是我认为的区别，
with EMDR is we call it this head heart lag, if you like, or this head heart distinction where people might have done a lot of talking therapy and going, well, yeah, logically I know it wasn't my fault or I know I'm safe, but it doesn't feel like that. And what we see in EMDR is when the high distress is dialed down, when the shopping bags get put down and the thinking brain can come online, the head can come online, we get a marrying up of the two. So the cupboard is no longer flinging open. Actually, the cupboard's now been, I say to clients, it's like we're going to empty the cupboard safely, carefully, bit by bit, we're going to sort out this stuff and put it somewhere else. So the door isn't, you know, stuffing a load of stuff away anymore. It's not, they're not vulnerable
在EMDR中，我们称之为这种“头脑与心灵的滞后”，如果你愿意的话，或者这种头脑与心灵的区别，人们可能进行了大量的谈话治疗，说，嗯，是的，逻辑上我知道那不是我的错，或者我知道我是安全的，但感觉并不像那样。而我们在EMDR中看到的是，当高度的痛苦被调低，当购物袋被放下，思考的大脑可以上线时，头脑可以上线，我们得到了两者的结合。所以柜子不再猛地打开。实际上，柜子现在已经被，我告诉来访者，就像我们要安全、仔细地一点一点清空柜子，我们要整理这些东西并把它们放在别处。所以门不再是，你知道，不再塞满一堆东西了。他们不再脆弱，
to the cupboard door flinging open anymore. And as you say, Marianne, you know, it's not always like a real quick win in EMDR. For some clients, it really is. For other clients, it's a much more of an up and down processing therapy, especially the longer term, more chronically traumatized someone is, the harder it is. But it will, it can get there for sure. But yeah, you're, you know, you talked about how visceral. And that's the head heart. That's the head body distinction, right? Because people literally feel stuff in the NDR, don't they?
不再容易受到柜门猛地打开的影响。正如你所说，Marian，你知道，EMDR并不总是像真正的快速胜利。对于一些来访者来说，确实如此。对于其他来访者来说，这是一种更多起伏的处理治疗，特别是长期、更慢性创伤的人，越难处理。但它肯定能达到目标。但是的，你，你知道，你谈到了它是多么发自内心。这就是头脑与心灵，这就是头脑与身体的区别，对吧？因为人们在EMDR中确实感受到了东西，不是吗？
And sometimes people don't like that because the feelings are horrible and they've done a really good job of cutting off from them. But if we can bring the feelings into the space safely and process them, and they can get filed away differently in the brain with that date stamp of it's over, that was then, not it's now. People really, really benefit from that. Had a veteran come to see me a few years back who had a very bad stammer when I met him to the point where I couldn't really understand a lot of what he was saying, which EMDR was grateful because you don't need to talk a lot in EMDR. But I really, that was one of these moments where he was a little bit stuck on something and I said something like, do you need to keep doing that now you're safe in
有时人们不喜欢那样，因为这些感受很可怕，他们已经很好地切断了与它们的联系。但如果我们能安全地将这些感受带入空间并处理它们，它们就可以在脑中以“它结束了，那是当时，而不是现在”的日期戳被归档。人们真的、真的从中受益。几年前，一位退伍军人来看我，当我见到他时，他有严重的口吃，以至于我无法真正理解他所说的大部分内容，这在EMDR中是值得庆幸的，因为在EMDR中你不需要说很多话。但我真的，那是其中一个时刻，他在某件事上有点卡住了，我说了一些类似的话，比如，既然你现在在
the UK? And he went, no. And I said, okay, go with that. And we added some more BLS. And he went, oh, something left my body and his stammer had gone. I mean, you know, it's just weird and amazing all in one go. But that talks to that how visceral stuff. And it's implicit. A lot of stuff is implicit for people. The brain hasn't had a chance to put the story on and make really good sense of it. If you think back to, you know, for some clients we're working with when they were really little and they won't have a coherent narrative of that event, but the body is holding the shopping bags. Yeah, what a really powerful moment and what a privilege to be there for these really authentic, vulnerable human moments. And obviously this can be incredibly difficult. You know,
英国是安全的，你还需要继续那样做吗？他说，不。我说，好的，顺着那个感觉。我们增加了一些双侧刺激（BLS）。他说，哦，有什么东西离开了我的身体，他的口吃消失了。我的意思是，你知道，这既奇怪又神奇。但这谈到了那种发自内心的东西。而且它是内隐的。很多东西对人们来说是内隐的。大脑没有机会把故事串联起来并做出很好的解释。如果你回想一下，你知道，对于一些我们正在共事的来访者，当他们还很小的时候，他们不会有那个事件连贯的叙述，但身体却背着购物袋。是的，多么强大的时刻，能为这些真正真实、脆弱的人类时刻而在场是一种荣幸。显然这可能非常困难。你知道，
you and I have both been in sessions with people, you and I have both probably been clients where we've just been like a snotty mess when we're having EMDR. Like it can be really, really evocative. But what I would say, and what I know you would want to make clear is this is not uncontainable,
你我都曾和人们一起进行过会话，你我也可能都曾是来访者，当我们进行EMDR时，我们只是像个鼻涕虫一样。它可能真的、真的非常令人动容。但我会说，而且我知道你会想明确一点，这不是无法控制的，
this is not unmanageable. You know, we would always make sure that a client was safe and could be well-resourced to be able to be stable so that they weren't left managing this after session. EMDR, I'm always really sad and disappointed when I get people coming to me saying, I had EMDR, it was absolutely awful, it was really retortizing, I never want that again. And often when I say, could you tell me a bit about that, like what, like how quickly did you get in processing it?
这并非无法处理。你知道，我们总是会确保客户是安全的，并且拥有充足的资源来保持稳定，这样他们就不会在治疗结束后独自面对这些问题。对于EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工疗法），每当有人来找我说“我做过EMDR，感觉糟透了，简直是二次创伤，我再也不想尝试了”，我总是感到非常难过和失望。通常当我问他们“你能跟我说说具体情况吗？比如，你们处理这些问题的速度有多快？”时，
And often I hear it straight away, we were processing straight away. And that, I know there are definitely therapists that do that and certainly there's a big, you know, group of people in the Netherlands who work in an inpatient service who do process with people really quickly. But it's within the containment and safety of an inpatient service, right? But I think what some EMDR therapists will, who have trained in it or not trained in it, which is the bigger issue, right, because anyone can go and do a training that isn't regulated. And this is where the problems can stem from. But yeah, some people think it's a technique. Like if I just do this to somebody, that's going to magically make their,
我经常听到他们说，我们马上就开始处理了。我知道确实有一些治疗师会这样做，而且在荷兰，确实有一大群在住院服务机构工作的人，他们处理问题的速度非常快。但那是在住院服务机构的约束和安全保障下进行的，对吧？但我认为，一些EMDR治疗师——无论他们是否受过相关培训，这才是更大的问题，因为任何人都可以去参加未经监管的培训，而问题往往就源于此——有些人认为这只是一种技巧。好像只要我对某人做这个动作，就能神奇地让他们的
trauma process. But actually, I'm a big, big advocate and I'm sure, you know, this is what Franciscine Shapiro was teaching is. You don't just sit in front of somebody and say, well, think of that and then start let the cupboard in the mind fling open. You and I know and all my supervisees work to, actually you spend a good amount of time building a strong relationship with that person, looking at their risk history, checking what they can and can't manage processing. And I always say to my clients, you didn't have control. the time of the trauma, I want you to have control in the room with me. You need to have a sense of being in the driving seat. I'm alongside you. I'm helping you navigate, but only you can decide
创伤得到处理。但实际上，我非常非常推崇——我相信这也是弗朗辛·夏皮罗（Francine Shapiro）所教导的——你不能只是坐在某人面前说“好吧，想想那件事”，然后就开始让心里的柜门大开。你和我都知道，我所有的督导对象也都遵循这一点：实际上，你需要花大量时间与那个人建立牢固的关系，查看他们的风险史，确认他们能处理和不能处理什么。我总是对我的客户说，在创伤发生时你没有控制权，但我希望你在和我共处的房间里拥有控制权。你需要有一种掌控感。我陪在你身边，帮你导航，但只有你能决定
how much you do or don't do and what you process. So I have some clients say, I'm coming for the car crash, I absolutely am not touching my childhood trauma and I'm like, fine. You know, we have to be respectful. But sometimes clients don't get that message. It's like just get on with it and we're going right back here to, you know, this stuff that happened to you when you were seven or eight. And clients don't know that actually they should have more of a voice than that. So no, EMDR should never be. It's not reliving. There's very much a mindfulness component with EMDR that should absolutely be present in every session,
你做多少或不做多少，以及你处理什么。所以我有些客户会说：“我是为了车祸来的，我绝对不会触碰我的童年创伤。”我会说：“没问题。”你知道，我们必须保持尊重。但有时客户并没有收到这个信息。他们觉得“赶紧处理吧，我们要回到这里，回到你七八岁时发生的那些事”。客户并不知道其实他们应该有更多的发言权。所以不，EMDR绝不应该是这样。它不是重温创伤。EMDR中有一个非常重要的正念成分，它绝对应该存在于每一次治疗中，
where we call it dual awareness. So whilst you're noticing this difficult thing here, you know, we've got some stuff out the cupboard. You're not reliving it. actually we need you to have very much a sense of safety in the here and now in the therapy space, whether that's online or whether that's physically in a room with somebody, we're saying to them from the safety of the now, I want you to just observe, just notice that thing that happened back then. They're not meant to be reliving it.
我们称之为“双重意识”。所以，当你注意到这里困难的事情时，你知道，我们从柜子里拿出了一些东西。你并不是在重温它。实际上，我们需要你在治疗空间里——无论是在线还是在房间里与某人面对面——有一种强烈的安全感。我们对他们说：“从现在的安全感出发，我希望你只是观察，只是注意到过去发生的那件事。”他们不应该是在重温它。
Obviously, people can get a bit flooded, but that's the therapist's role, is to co-regulate that person in the space where we're not meant to sit silently and just say nothing and be completely neutral. We're not interfering with the processing, but we absolutely are holding the space non-verbally, verbally. You know, we're not talking to them the whole time, but they should be very aware of our presence. Yeah, I really agree with you that this is safer in inexperienced kind of hands.
显然，人们有时会感到情绪泛滥，但这就是治疗师的角色，是在这个空间里与那个人进行共同调节。我们不应该只是沉默地坐着，什么都不说，保持完全中立。我们不会干扰处理过程，但我们绝对是在非语言和语言上支撑着这个空间。你知道，我们不会一直跟他们说话，但他们应该非常清楚我们的存在。是的，我非常同意你的观点，在缺乏经验的人手中，这确实不够安全。
And I didn't learn this until I was already a qualified psychologist. And it felt like it was an additional tool in my toolkit. But I'm very glad it's not my only tool in my toolkit, because like you, I believe that, you know, all the other things I've learned along the way and had experience of with clients are so important. Absolutely. And I was going to say, you know, for accredited trainers, EMDR trainers in the UK, you know, we've all gone through pretty rigorous, you know, things in order to demonstrate our competencies. And that's why there's an eligibility criteria to get on accredited trainings. You already need to be a pretty well-established therapist.
我直到成为合格的心理学家后才学习这个。它感觉就像是我工具箱里的一个额外工具。但我很高兴它不是我工具箱里唯一的工具，因为和你一样，我相信我一路学到的所有其他东西以及与客户积累的经验都非常重要。绝对是这样。我正想说，对于英国的认证培训师，EMDR培训师，我们都经历过相当严格的考核来证明我们的能力。这就是为什么参加认证培训有资格标准。你本身就需要是一位相当成熟的治疗师，
because you need the foundational skills. If you don't have the skills to sit with someone in their distress and manage risk and co-regulate someone and know who to ring and what to do if someone is quite distressed or you don't know how to bring someone back into their window of tolerance, you shouldn't be doing EMDR. That's why there's an eligibility criteria
因为你需要基础技能。如果你没有能力陪伴处于痛苦中的人，没有能力管理风险、进行共同调节，不知道在某人非常痛苦时该给谁打电话、该做什么，或者不知道如何将某人带回他们的“耐受窗口”，你就不应该做EMDR。这就是为什么会有资格标准，
and that's why I get frustrated when people set themselves up as trainers who have none of those skills and actively advertise we don't have an eligibility criteria. And I think what a shame for the public who won't know the difference, you know, because they don't know. Someone advertises that they're an EMDR therapist,
这也是为什么当有些人没有任何这些技能却把自己包装成培训师，并积极宣传“我们没有资格标准”时，我会感到沮丧。我认为这对公众来说太遗憾了，因为他们不知道其中的区别，他们不了解。有人宣传自己是EMDR治疗师，
go and have EMDR, have a really, sometimes really bad experience. And they're more traumatized and never want to do it again. Absolutely. So, you know, there are different levels of qualification and experience with EMDR. Can you take us through what they might look like, Alex? Sure. Yeah. So to get on accredited training in the UK, as I said, you already have to meet an eligibility
人们去做了EMDR，有时会有非常糟糕的体验。他们受到了更严重的创伤，再也不想尝试了。绝对是这样。所以，EMDR的资格和经验有不同的级别。亚历克斯，你能带我们了解一下这些级别是什么样的吗？当然。是的，正如我所说，要在英国参加认证培训，你必须先满足资格
criteria and that, you know, I'm not going to tell you about all of them right here because they're on the EMDR Association UK's website and they're on my training website and all the other trainers' websites. But your first, different trainers do it slightly differently. Some like me will have three parts, some have what we call four parts and that's essentially because they've split the supervision day into two halves to give people a little bit longer to get things under their belt and also a whole day of supervision is quite long for people, you know, so you can probably imagine. But the material covered is to all intents and purposes the same. So all trainers will have to do 24 hours of teaching, 18 hours of practicals and 10 hours of
标准。我不会在这里一一列举，因为它们都在英国EMDR协会的网站上，也在我的培训网站以及其他培训师的网站上。但首先，不同的培训师做法略有不同。像我这样的人会分为三个部分，有些人分为四个部分，这本质上是因为他们把督导日分成了两半，给人们多一点时间来掌握知识，而且一整天的督导对人们来说确实太长了，你知道，你可以想象一下。但所涵盖的内容在所有意图和目的上都是一样的。所以所有的培训师都必须完成24小时的教学、18小时的实践和10小时的
supervision. So some people might do level one or part one. We call it part one, part two, part three and or part four, depending on which trainer they're going with. That's called a standard training and at that stage you can call yourself a part one trained EMDR therapist or a part three trained EMDR therapist. Then that's not accredited. There's no assessment process for that. Obviously, you have to join in in all the activities on the trainings and you have to demonstrate a level of competency, but we're not assessing you on that because you're just literally learning. It's like the learning to drive, but then the getting good at it comes with the supervision and the hours of having a go and like you said we're you know learning through our mistakes sometimes
督导。所以有些人可能会完成第一级或第一部分。我们称之为第一部分、第二部分、第三部分和/或第四部分，取决于他们选择哪位培训师。这被称为标准培训，在这个阶段，你可以称自己为“第一部分受训的EMDR治疗师”或“第三部分受训的EMDR治疗师”。但这还不是认证。这没有评估过程。显然，你必须参加培训中的所有活动，并且必须展示出一定的能力水平，但我们不会对此进行评估，因为你只是在学习。这就像学开车，但变得熟练则来自于督导以及大量的实践时间，就像你说的，我们有时通过错误来学习，
aren't we and and some of the most important learning experiences come through that but so the next level up from that which is called accredited is practitioner which you can apply for just around about one year after you finish your part three so you have to be fully standard trained in order to then go towards practitioner and that is very much more of a rigorous assessment process where you need to see a minimum of 25 clients that you've processed with. You need to have had another 10 hours minimum of supervision on top of what you had on your training. It's a very competency based.
不是吗？一些最重要的学习经验正是来自于此。所以，比这高一级的级别被称为“认证从业者”（Practitioner），你可以在完成第三部分后大约一年申请。你必须先完成标准培训，才能申请成为从业者。这是一个更加严格的评估过程，你需要至少处理过25个客户。除了培训期间的督导外，你还需要额外至少10小时的督导。这是一个非常基于能力的评估。
So it's not even a numbers game. Some people will say, well, I must be nearly there now because I've done, you know, they might contact to me via my website and say, oh, could you see me through to practitioner? Because I've done 23 clients. I'm nearly there. And I'm like, well, I actually need to be confident that you know what you're doing. So that's going to probably be another year, if I'm honest with me, before I feel like that,
所以这甚至不是一个数字游戏。有些人会说：“好吧，我一定快到了，因为我已经……”他们可能会通过我的网站联系我，说：“哦，你能带我完成从业者认证吗？因为我已经处理了23个客户，快到了。”我会说：“好吧，我实际上需要确信你知道自己在做什么。”如果说实话，在我感觉我们达到那个水平之前，可能还需要一年时间，
we're there because you have to see video footage and everything. So you can hear it's quite an extra bit of work on compared to like your standard training. But it does demonstrate good clinical competency. If you get there, you can go on the EMDR Association map and be searchable. And then, you know, that's kind of your seal of approval. If you've made it to the map, you've demonstrated your competency at practitioner level. And then from there, if people, want to, they can then go on to become a consultant. So you're in a essentially what we call
因为你必须查看视频片段等等。所以你可以听出来，这比标准培训要多出不少工作量。但这确实证明了良好的临床能力。如果你达到了这个水平，你就可以进入EMDR协会的地图并被搜索到。然后，你知道，这就是你的“质量保证印章”。如果你进入了地图，就证明了你在从业者级别的能力。从那里开始，如果人们愿意，他们可以继续成为督导（Consultant）。所以你本质上处于我们所说的
consultant in training period for a minimum of three years after practitioner level. Some people take longer. Some people are like really, you know, get through it really quickly and I really adapted it. But it's another three years minimum from practitioner level. And for that, it's much more about your supervision of other people. So really understanding that standard protocol and many other treatment plans inside out back to front and being able to support someone else to learn how to do EMDR but they're not teaching people EMDR that's a trainer that would do that and then the next level up from there is facilitator where people might work towards facilitating trainings and again that's several years on from there and then someone might
“督导实习期”，在从业者级别之后至少需要三年。有些人需要更长时间。有些人真的很快就通过了，我真的很适应。但从从业者级别算起，至少还需要三年。对于那个级别，更多的是关于你对其他人的督导。所以要真正理解标准方案和许多其他治疗计划，做到烂熟于心，并能够支持其他人学习如何做EMDR。但他们不是教别人EMDR，那是培训师做的事。再往上一级是“引导师”（Facilitator），人们可能会朝着引导培训的方向努力，这又是几年之后的事了，然后有人可能会
become a trainer and then they might become a senior trainer so there's like multiple sort of gateways, if you like. But practitioners, your first level where it's like, right, you've demonstrated this competency and you're on the map. Amazing. Thank you so much, Alex. And I know that having been, you know, your supervisor for quite a few years now, I know that you have, you know, you were doing, you're facilitating and then you are now a trainer as well. And you've got your own training company. Could you tell us a little bit about what you offer, Alex? Yeah. So we've got two businesses essentially. The business that I see you in is my what I call my therapy and supervision business. So that's where I see my own clinical caseload because as a, no matter how high up you are
成为培训师，然后他们可能会成为高级培训师。所以如果你愿意的话，有多种“关卡”。但从业者是你第一个级别，意味着“好了，你已经证明了这种能力，你已经在地图上了”。太棒了。非常感谢你，亚历克斯。我知道作为你几年的督导，我知道你一直在做引导工作，现在你也是一名培训师了。你还有自己的培训公司。你能告诉我们一些你提供的服务吗，亚历克斯？好的。我们本质上经营两项业务。我见到你的那项业务是我所谓的“治疗与督导业务”。这就是我处理自己临床病例的地方，因为无论你级别多高，
in EMDR, you obviously still need to keep your feet on the ground and do the work yourself. So we as trainers, facilitators, we always still have a therapy caseload. So my one side of the business is therapy where I see clients. They often come through my website or and then I do a lot of supervision online for clinicians like you in private practice or I do a huge amount of NHS supervision. Again, mostly online. So that's the one strand of the business. And then more recently we set up a training business. So I qualified late 2024. But in the time it took us to get everything up and running, we ran our first training in April 2025. And we've run a few now. So we're based in South Devon.
在EMDR领域，你显然仍然需要脚踏实地，亲自做临床工作。所以作为培训师、引导师，我们仍然会有治疗病例。所以我业务的一方面是治疗，我在这里接待客户。他们通常通过我的网站找到我，然后我为像你这样的私人执业临床医生提供大量的在线督导，或者我做大量的NHS（英国国家医疗服务体系）督导。同样，大部分是在线进行的。这是业务的一条主线。然后最近我们成立了一家培训公司。我是在2024年底获得资格的。但在我们筹备一切的时间里，我们在2025年4月进行了第一次培训。我们现在已经举办了几次。所以我们的基地在南德文郡。
We only currently offer in-person training because it's very experiential. And actually I feel like for me, where I'm at with training at the minute, I want to have eyes on people in the room and be able to read the room and see how people are understanding what I'm saying, but also for the practical side of things.
我们目前只提供线下培训，因为这非常注重体验。实际上我觉得，就我目前的培训阶段而言，我希望在房间里能看到人们，能够观察现场氛围，看看人们是如何理解我所说的话的，同时也为了实践方面的考虑。
I feel like you genuinely learn it much better when you're actually physically sat with someone having a go and you've got someone overseeing that and supporting you and noticing. And I just think whilst learning EMDR online is great, and I'm not saying I wouldn't move towards that at some point, there's something about being in breakout rooms and not being visible all the time that stuff can get missed and lost a little bit. And certainly when I've supervised people who trained purely online, when it comes to doing it in person with somebody, they're like, oh, I don't know. I'm not really sure about sitting with someone and doing that. So we offer the training. Like I said, we're in the Southwest.
我觉得当你真正和某人坐在一起尝试，并且有人监督和支持你、观察你时，你确实学得更好。我只是觉得，虽然在线学习EMDR很棒，我并不是说我将来不会转向那种方式，但有些东西在分组讨论室里是无法完全展现的，有些细节可能会被遗漏。当然，当我督导那些纯粹在线受训的人时，当他们需要与某人面对面进行治疗时，他们会说：“哦，我不知道。我不确定该怎么和某人坐在一起做这件事。”所以我们提供培训。就像我说的，我们在西南部。
so we physically have venues in Bristol and Torquay. But we do run in-house trainings. We've run some for Cornwall. We've run some for Avon and Wiltshire. And we're open to kind of going around the country and doing stuff. But yeah, that's what we do really. We're moving more towards being 50-50 therapy supervision and then the other side of the business being training.
所以我们在布里斯托尔和托基有实体场地。但我们也进行内部培训。我们为康沃尔郡举办过，为埃文和威尔特郡举办过。我们愿意去全国各地做这些事。但是的，这就是我们所做的。我们正朝着50%治疗督导、50%培训的业务模式发展。
Oh, we don't work with children. That's probably worth saying. So I'm a standard trainer. so I don't have, even in my clinical psychology career, I think I did one child placement, you know, it wasn't my thing. And so I've never, I did a little bit of child work because I did child training in EMDR and I did a little, I dipped my toe in. But actually, I think, honestly, from my perspective, I think you need to have the core skills like we were saying in working with children and families if you're going to offer EMDR to children. So, but what we have done is
哦，我们不接待儿童。这可能值得一提。我是一名标准培训师。所以即使在我的临床心理学职业生涯中，我想我也只做过一次儿童实习，你知道，那不是我的强项。所以我从来没有……我做过一点儿童工作，因为我参加过EMDR的儿童培训，我浅尝辄止。但实际上，老实说，从我的角度来看，我认为如果你要为儿童提供EMDR，你需要具备我们刚才提到的与儿童和家庭工作的核心技能。所以，我们所做的是
collaborate with a lady called Alice Bine, who is a child and adolescent trainer, but she's based up in Lincoln, but she's collaborating with us to bring EMDR child training to the Southwest because there aren't any currently down here. Great. And I was just going to say, I'm aware that someone that we both met at one of my in-person psychology events, she is not based down in the Southwest, but treated it as an opportunity to have a few days on holiday in a hotel, and so joined you from the Midlands. So, you know, if you're willing to travel, Yeah, and the Bristol one's actually in a spa hotel. Lovely.
与一位名叫爱丽丝·拜恩（Alice Bine）的女士合作，她是一位儿童和青少年培训师，基地在林肯，但她正在与我们合作，将EMDR儿童培训带到西南部，因为目前这里还没有。太棒了。我正想说，我知道我们在我的一次线下心理学活动中见过的一个人，她不在西南部，但她把这当作一个在酒店度假几天的机会，所以从中部地区加入了你们。所以，如果你愿意旅行的话……是的，布里斯托尔的那场培训实际上是在一家水疗酒店。太好了。
You know, it's not to like. Absolutely, yeah. So people do use it as a getaway. Like they'll come down, have, like, the training is three days, but people might stay four or five. And we have discounted rates at the hotels. And especially if you come in the sort of summer season and, you know, from sort of April onwards down here,
你知道，这没什么不好。绝对是这样。所以人们确实把它当作一个度假。他们会过来，培训是三天，但人们可能会待四五天。我们在酒店有折扣价。特别是如果你在夏季，比如4月以后来这里，
it's really quite buzzing in Turkey. And there's been lots of regeneration in the area. So, yeah, it's quite being. by the sea, people often come from, you know, places that, like you said, in the Midlands that are not, haven't got any sea near them for miles and they'll come down here and it's quite a refreshing break. How nice. I could talk to you all day, Alex. Where can people learn more about you and your work? What's your website? Yeah, so my website is wwww.combe button hyphen EMDR training.co.uk.
托基非常热闹。该地区进行了很多重建。所以，是的，这很棒。在海边，人们经常从像你说的中部地区过来，那里方圆几英里都没有海，他们会来这里，这是一个非常令人耳目一新的休息。多好啊。亚历克斯，我可以跟你聊一整天。人们在哪里可以了解更多关于你和你工作的信息？你的网站是什么？好的，我的网站是 www.combebutton-EMDRtraining.co.uk。
But if you googled Alex button EMDR training, it would show up in the searches as well. And within that, we have a membership area that we've just generated in the last few months for our training delegates, but we open it up to EMDR therapists who've trained with another accredited trainer because lots of people were saying to us
但如果你在谷歌搜索“Alex Button EMDR training”，它也会出现在搜索结果中。在网站内，我们有一个会员区，这是我们在过去几个月里为我们的培训学员创建的，但我们也向那些在其他认证培训师那里受过培训的EMDR治疗师开放，因为很多人对我们说，
it's a lot of information to take in in seven days. And I'd really would love to be able to watch it back or be able to come into like a joint kind of space to ask questions. So we generated the Refresh and Master membership area, which is also available via the website. So our training delegates get that for free for a year. But then people who've trained with other people can also, as long as they can prove that they've trained properly,
在七天内要吸收的信息量太大了。我真的很想能够回看，或者能够进入一个联合空间来提问。所以我们创建了“刷新与大师”（Refresh and Master）会员区，也可以通过网站访问。我们的培训学员可以免费使用一年。但那些在其他人那里受过培训的人，只要能证明他们受过正规培训，
they can apply and have a monthly subscription to that. So that's got all the training videos, downloadable resources, links to lots of things, to a WhatsApp group, that's private and questions are only answered by consultants that I know and two hours worth of drop in sessions a month where people can drop in. It's not clinical supervision, but it's like a place to say, I got a bit stuck with this or can you tell me a bit more about EMDR for that? So we offer that in the membership area as well and that's available by the website.
也可以申请并按月订阅。那里有所有的培训视频、可下载资源、大量链接、一个私密的WhatsApp群组，问题只由我认识的督导回答，还有每月两小时的答疑环节，人们可以随时加入。这不是临床督导，但这是一个可以说“我在这里卡住了”或者“你能多告诉我一些关于EMDR处理那个问题的信息吗”的地方。所以我们在会员区也提供这些服务，可以通过网站访问。
Perfect. Amazing. Thank you so much for your time, Alex. You really are like lovely at this and really good at what you do. So thank you for being a lovely yes. Thank you for inviting me. So lovely to have you. Thanks Alex. Wow. What a lovely chance to chat with Alex on camera. I am always just I just feel so lucky to get to spend time with Alex. She's so wise and being able to do so on camera sharing it with you feels like a real treat as well. She just has a way of breaking things that make everything seem to make sense. I hope that you've got someone like that for you in your life. She's also really funny and I love having her in my world for that reason too.
太完美了。太棒了。非常感谢你的时间，亚历克斯。你真的很擅长这个，而且工作非常出色。所以谢谢你成为一个可爱的嘉宾。谢谢你邀请我。很高兴有你。谢谢亚历克斯。哇。能和亚历克斯在镜头前聊天真是太好了。我总是觉得能和亚历克斯共度时光真是太幸运了。她非常有智慧，能在镜头前分享这些感觉真是一种享受。她有一种把复杂事物拆解开来，让一切都变得合情合理的能力。我希望你的生活中也有这样的人。她也非常幽默，出于这个原因，我也很喜欢她在我的世界里。
We got together in person for the first time last summer at an in-person psychology networking event and it was really special. I love working with clinicians that are human and, you know, excellent at what they're do and that's what I aim to bring you in psychology actually. If you're not already following Dr. Alex Button on Instagram or LinkedIn, please do so. Her details are in the show notes or on screen. I certainly learn a lot from being in her world on LinkedIn where she's Dr. Alex Button. If you're an aspiring psychologist and you are striving to be a clinical psychologist,
去年夏天我们在一次线下心理学社交活动中第一次见面，那真的很特别。我喜欢与有人情味且工作出色的临床医生合作，这正是我在《心理学其实》（Psychology Actually）中想要带给你们的。如果你还没有在Instagram或LinkedIn上关注亚历克斯·巴顿博士，请务必关注。她的详细信息在节目说明中或屏幕上。我从她在LinkedIn上的分享中学到了很多，她在那里叫亚历克斯·巴顿博士。如果你是一位有抱负的心理学家，并且正在努力成为一名临床心理学家，
much like myself and Dr. Alex, then I think you'll really find the aspiring psychologist. membership helpful. You can join from just £30 a month with no minimum term. There are details on screen or you can head to www.a aspiring hyphen psychologist.co.com. If this episode has wet your appetite for learning a little bit about trauma and how it shows up in practice, then why not? Head along to the episode I did about nobody's child, which is the book by Virginia Roberts-Grae. Don't forget that we've got an extra brand new episode of Psychology actually which is coming out midweek, coming out Wednesday evenings both on YouTube and wherever you get your podcast on MP3. It's called Inner Work. And I think if you like the main episodes, I think you might just like the new Inner Work ones which are now completely free. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
就像我和亚历克斯博士一样，那么我想你会发现“有抱负的心理学家”（Aspiring Psychologist）会员区很有帮助。你每月只需30英镑即可加入，没有最低期限。屏幕上有详细信息，或者你可以访问 www.aspiring-psychologist.co.uk。如果这一集激发了你对了解创伤及其在实践中如何表现的兴趣，那么为什么不听听我关于《没人要的孩子》（Nobody's Child）那一集呢，那是弗吉尼亚·罗伯茨-格雷（Virginia Roberts-Grae）的书。别忘了我们还有《心理学其实》的额外全新一集，在周中发布，周三晚上在YouTube和任何你获取播客的地方发布。它叫《内在工作》（Inner Work）。如果你喜欢主集，我想你可能也会喜欢新的《内在工作》系列，现在完全免费。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。